[Music]
you just call you mom like an hour ago
so I try to see what else who is going
to be a say lots of things anyway
tonight your business hi mom
yeah yep know what now you can't weigh
that share what's wrong with it
look you can't be this funny funny guy
all the time please can you just wear
something appropriate to the event well
why should you kill joy as the my own
style I like it
[Music]
what what's going on I think know what
why are you wearing oh oh oh this well I
decided that I was fed up of us having
arguments about your obsessive cleaning
and you know what I'm just going to
understand give it up and I'm going to
live in a biochemical hazard suit you
know limit the spread of my bacteria
around your precious apartment
oh it's amazing
yeah that's for me because of my
excessive cleaning well you would have
missed of it I'm going yeah Drac hold on
to it
what don't you wish for the text for
tomorrow what time is the flight 10 hair
o'clock should be fine
eight are you joking why are you saying
erotic about airports I'm not I just
make sure were punctual that's all I
think that's everything okay careful
what the flights up to more after 10
a.m. yeah I know
haha worried about missing it as well I
was thinking about what you said all the
things we can go wrong I thought
probably best to get the departure
lounge good 9 hours before the flight
leaves so what oh c'mon the taxi there
go
you
you
[Music]
you